just updated Valley numbers and it's a
little cool in some spots Mountains Edge
down to 37 Seven Hills at 39 pahrumps in
the 30s as well on the other side of the
spring mountains 39 in Summerlin 37 at
Nella so it's pretty cool it's still
been a little windy up in the spring
mountains as well roll back the radar
suits you can see boy some of that rain
was pretty heavy southeast of Las Vegas
snow ended a little earlier than
expected yesterday in the winter storm
warnings were actually canceled ahead of
schedule so they did not last until
early hours of this morning Harris
Springs several rain gauges in the
mid-levels of the spring mountains
two-thirds of an inch of rain as I said
Red Rock over a quarter of an inch
Henderson a quarter of an inch of rain
Sky Canyon as well as Centennial Hills
picking up about 16 hundredths of an
inch but look at this almost four tenths
of an inch near Boulder City Mesquite a
third of an inch Pahrump a quarter of an
inch of rain and near the Las Vegas
Motor Speedway two tenths of an inch of
rain now the next system already winding
up on the west coast and it's pushing
some showers and a little bit of higher
elevation snow already into Northern
California San Francisco will get rain
today as well as the Pacific Northwest a
warm-up is on the way for the East Coast
as warm air is being pushed up ahead of
the cold so wow if you're traveling you
might just put some shorts in the
suitcase for some Eastern destinations
58 degrees for us today warmer than
yesterday's low 50s Sunshine Galore
today mostly sunny Saturday but clouds
return on Sunday as the next system
lined up behind the one currently in the
Pacific will bring us a chance of rain
on Monday and again especially on
Tuesday